saying when do we get to see real
gameplay of it well tonight's the night
please welcome from EA Riley Cooper come
on up ma'am how you doing all right so
me for speed heat we saw the
announcement last week tell us a bit
about this game how is it new or
different for Need for Speed well you
know it focuses on the core experience
of street racing and modified cars at
night with cops into this we've added
sanction racing by day to keep that
experience fresh and help explain why
all these racers are in town all right
sounds pretty cool we want to see you
guys want to see the gameplay so how we
do the honors Riley let's see let's
check it out Need for Speed Heat welcome
to Palm City fresh world
with new customizations and the return
of cops make Palm City and urban oasis
for those who burn fast and live by
their own rules the daytime off with
sanctioned racing events through the
Speed Hunter show they compete and score
Bank with each new wind then use the
rewards to tweak your car's performance
and visual customization cops patrol the
streets during the day but they play by
the rules
finding you for speeding and limiting
your progress using controlled moves to
slow you down roam the open-world nab
challenges and collectibles as much time
here as you like when you ready switch
into night build your rep i competing an
illicit street races the more you win
the more your heat will rise in the more
rep you'll gain and all the eyes on you
comes with the price tops are on another
level at night and you'll become a
target as your heat level increases as
it gets higher they'll ratchet up their
efforts to stop
leashing helicopters and rhinos to take
you down we've coordinated efforts that
adapt to the situation push it too far
and they won't hold back and your car
can only take so much damage so be sure
to make it to a hideout or the garage
without getting busted otherwise you'll
lose everything you've risked step into
your garage where you can tune your
setup to your like pick a car and make
it your own we've replaced the speed
cards from payback
you can now unlock parts by building up
rep at night use the bank you've earned
during the day to level up your ride
almost every car can be transformed into
a custom win the revamp material editor
adds a dynamic range of style
combinations while the new exhaust
tuning system did you ride a bar to go
with this bike
man go beyond the car craft and create
your own unique avatar to represent your
style Palm City
for the first time ever a need for speed
you can now customize your favorite
rides throwing out download need for
speed heat studio today for an early
acces into car customization with weekly
car drops a full line of custom parts
and a rap editor you can now build your
custom ride and connect your account to
push it directly into the game get the
app and show off your need for speed
style today all Drive will be available
in lunch crew up with your friends but
let us pair you up with others so you
never ride alone you Cruise rides will
be displayed in you garage you're always
up to speed with the latest creations
leaderboards and challenges are tightly
connected to the crew so push each other
to be the best and get a one-up on the
wall every day is dangerous every race
means risk another chance to lose
everything you've worked for
turn the key burn all limits
[Applause]
all right so I saw heat studio there
that and I can basically build my car
now in advance of the games I how it
works
that's right heat studio is an awesome
app you can have access to full visual
customization of most of the cars in our
car list when you've done your designs
you can push them to the need for speed
heat the full game when it launches
November 8th worldwide ok and heat
studio when is that coming up it's
available in most territories on iOS
worldwide on Android right now right now
I said right now all right there you go
that's gonna make the real alright be
for sweetie - so you can download that
Android and iOS and check it out all
right well that's very cool Need for
Speed oh there's the QR code by the way
if you guys want to snap it right now
grab the app there are cool Need for
Speed heat coming in November thanks
very much for Ally appreciate you
hanging out thanks for awesome thanks
Riley for me I appreciate Riley
alright we got some more announcements
to make for you now this is one that
again another big surprise for everyone
check it out another world premiere
right here for